all right i'm laura ingram this is the
ingram angle from wyoming tonight we
have a lot to get to so we're going to
dive right in
all about liz that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now all high and mighty liz cheney has
spent basically the last year claiming
to be the supreme defender of the
constitution
i will never put party above my duty to
the constitution i swore an oath under
god and i will abide by that oath i'm a
conservative republican
and i believe deeply in the policies of
limited government those of us
who believe in republican principles and
ideals have a responsibility to try to
lead the party back to what it can be
our nation is preserved by those who
abide by their oaths to our constitution
but in reality right now liz cheney is
leading an attack on the presidency
itself
so hauling white house counsel pat
sipoloni in for questioning via subpoena
after he had already talked to the
committee voluntarily by the way it's
just a sign of growing desperation by a
woman who understands that her political
career is essentially over
she's trying to stretch her 15 minutes
of fame regardless of how much damage
she does to the white house to the
principle of separation of powers and of
course to the constitution
now think about it this way
how on earth is any president supposed
to have candid conversations with his
white house counsel frankly about
anything
if he believes that that white house
counsel can be dragged before a partisan
congressional committee that is
hell-bent on doing whatever it can to
keep its base happy and torture the
president
and by the way liz cheney isn't just a
wrecking ball to the constitution she's
an unrepentant liar
she isn't just smearing trump by the way
she's smearing the entire country that
voted for trump
and she repeatedly lies about what the
america first movement is all about
the reality that we face today as
republicans
as we think about the choice in front of
us we have to choose because republicans
cannot both be loyal to donald trump
and loyal to the constitution
oh really
like who gave you the you know the
authority to say that like 72 million 74
million americans voted for trump and
none of them count
in fact we are the ones trying to save
the constitution liz from you and your
new pals who want to abolish i don't
know just the senate eliminate the
electoral college destroy the supreme
court force americans to submit to
global rules made by international
bureaucrats just that
repeatedly and consistent consistently
cheney has taken the side of pelosi and
the hard left against the constitution
she's also repeatedly lied about the
events of january 6. he summoned a mob
to washington
he knew they were armed on january 6 he
knew they were angry
and he directed the violent mob to march
on the capitol
i mean the notion that hundreds of
people wandering through the capital
represented an attempt to subvert the us
government and that was the plan all
it's just ludicrous
we know that virtually everyone in the
american populist movement opposed the
events of january 6 they announced their
opposition at the time and they've
repeatedly stated that any law breakers
from that day should be punished
but as for president trump he certainly
never indicated that he intended to
overthrow the constitution instead he
did dispute the vote count just as
democrats did in 2000 2004
and 2016.
objection is in writing signed by a
number of members of the house of
representatives the objection today is
raised because there are irregularities
across this country with regard to
voting
i have an objection because 10 of the 29
electoral votes cast by florida were
cast by electors not lawfully certified
it's like k-10 greatest hits there well
also let's not forget that cheney's lies
hurt america here in the united states
most americans and certainly the great
majority of republicans know that she's
just trying to get revenge for her loss
of influence inside the gop the gop has
moved on from liz cheney
but in the rest of the world her smears
and her lies will be used by our
nation's enemies as anti-american
propaganda to discourage their people
from working with us
and let's not forget that cheney is
allied with the radical anti-americans
on the left right now
she wants nancy pelosi to remain as
speaker of the house
so by supporting pelosi and the
democrats cheney encourages the radical
anti-americanism that tears down our
statues hurts our standard of living
undermines our military trashes our
culture generally tells the rest of the
world that america is and always has
been evil
so at this point you might wonder like
why has cheney turned against america
while claiming she's the supreme
defender of the constitution
why is she using her last few months of
her career in congress to pursue
vengeance and spread lies well i don't
know i think the answer is obvious
she belonged to a political movement the
bush cheney movement that was committed
to open borders endless wars shipping
jobs to china making sure that roe vs
wade would never ever be overturned you
just use that for to get elected
so in 2015 and 2016 the republican base
effectively ended the bush-cheney
movement
choosing new leadership that would
actually try try to help americans
instead of hurting them
but democrats and want to be democrats
like liz cheney and adam kinziger they
only care about holding on to that last
shred of power in the old glory days
but that power is slipping away from
them
bob corker jeff flake they already left
the senate pat toomey he's going to be
gone at the end of the year george p
bush is a nice guy but he was
annihilated in his primary in cheyney
she's next
of course she's not going to go quietly
do you see yourself running for
president as a way to
prevent what you say would be the
destruction of the party you know
damaging our country
i haven't made a decision about that yet
and
i'm i'm obviously very focused on my
reelection i'm very focused on the
january 6th committee i'm very focused
on my obligations to do the job that i
have now
and i'll make a decision about 24 down
the road
i mean this is why people think
washington is completely delusional
totally separated from the way real
people live their lives that comment
so whatever she decides though she can
count on unlimited support from the
regime media that longs for the day when
republicans like liz cheney merely
pretended to disagree with the clintons
while essentially implementing virtually
the same policies as the democrats
there needs to be republicans of courage
liz cheney is one of those republicans
liz cheney in particular is showing us
that courage is contagious congresswoman
liz cheney offering some much needed
truth during a time of so many dangerous
lies
liberals and never trumpers they love
liz
but they're not the voters here in
wyoming who it seems to me
are tired of her tedious games
this is a great and beautiful state and
the people of this state deserve a
representative who's more interested in
advancing wyoming's interests
than liz cheney's own rabid crusade
against the old gop
so forget trump for a minute
do you think liz cheney is going to be
supporting
or campaigning for someone like ron
desantis or mike pompeo if they run for
president and let's say she doesn't run
of course she won't be remember her
litmus test is
if you do not denounce trump
you are a danger to america and frankly
you need to be canceled
liz cheney is where she is because she
has a famous father
that is literally the only reason she
won her house seat here in wyoming in
the first place
but america is a representative
democracy it is not an aristocracy
and next month liz cheney is going to
see and feel democracy in action
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else